as I noted last night it was terrific
for the president to let the sunlight
end during that dacha back and forth at
the White House
transparency is long overdue in the
legislative process it's something I've
been asking for for years he was engaged
and he was enthusiastic about having
both sides at the table that was really
good he also reiterated that the wall
and ending chain migration was a
prerequisite for any deal on the
so-called dreamers but not so reassuring
was when this went down
you turn on Fox News and I can hear the
drumbeat coming right wing radio and TV
talk show hosts are going to beat their
crap out of us because it's going to be
amnesty all over again and then the
president basically seconded that
emotion thank you you know it's very
interesting because I do have people
that are it's just to use a very common
term gray far-right and very far left
they're very unhappy about what we're
doing but I really don't believe they
have to be excuse me
Lindsey Graham hitting Fox News so
that's nothing new but the president
hitting the far right that's adopting
the language of his fiercest critics on
the left and many in the open borders
crowd pretty surprising and then here
was the PSD resistance this group comes
back hopefully with an agreement this
group and others from the Senate from
the house comes back with an agreement
I'm signing it I mean I will be signing
it I'm not going to say oh gee I want
this or I want that help you sign again
and here's the part that made Jeb Bush
all warm and fuzzy this should be a
bipartisan bill there should be a bill
of love truly should be a bill of love
and we can do that wait does that sound
a little bit familiar yes they broke the
law but it's not a felony it's kind of a
it's it's a it's a it's a it's an act of
love now do you remember when candidate
Trump ridiculed low-energy Jeb for the
if you remember he said they come as an
act of love
okay tell that to the families and there
are many many many families who lost a
loved one act of love okay there's no
act of love and remember candidate Trump
saying this no citizenship no services
[Applause]
let me go step further
they'll pay back taxes they have to pay
taxes there's no
there's no I understand listen to the
crowd
so what happened well maybe the
president realizes that he's never gonna
get a wall unless he does that daca
amnesty maybe and maybe he thinks he
just can't end chain migration unless he
gives legal status to those 800,000
illegals they range from about 16 years
of age to about 30 years of age and not
all kids now but that is a hard pill for
many of his most loyal supporters to
swallow today many of my radio listeners
were in meltdown mode we're not gonna
get a new wall out that my shirt we
don't get it we don't care so I'll bet
my shirt on that if he breaks his
promise and he grants amnesty to these
dreamers it's it's it's over I think
it's over my kids were born and raised
in America we have dreams too you know
if we don't we don't obey the law nobody
comes and gives us free stuff we are not
far right when we simply insist on
abiding by the legal immigration rules
and national sovereignty when did that
ever become far right I'm feeling
deflated right now well I did my best to
buck up the listeners but it wasn't easy
now it's true President Trump is winning
praise for his newfound openness to
things like comprehensive immigration
reform we all know that's mass amnesty
but he's winning it from some of the
same people who are enemies of his
populist agenda and by the way the same
people who revile his supporters I
thought that it was great to see our
friends in both parties in there opening
it up and talk to each other there was a
positive feeling about that this is the
presidency that many people thought
Donald Trump was capable of just the
notion of him being in command I think
it was very helpful both before the
cameras left and after they left that's
a guy who wrote the book just trashing
Trump but didn't even vote for him well
not so long ago like yesterday they were
calling you mr. president and your
agenda far-right extreme right racist
xenophobic all right
president's new friends the bipartisan
cabal that's been pushing amnesty for
years have a few goals in mind the
Republicans they want cheap labor and
the Democrats they want new voters who
are captive to big government but
there's another goal that the
establishment hopes to accomplish they
want to separate Donald Trump from his
base and break the spirit of the
populist movement well they're not going
to succeed they think they will though
because people like Steve Bannon is
sidelined and they think their moment
has arrived
the president has to remain loyal to his
supporters and to his agenda the one he
ran on the one that won all that
applause and rave reviews all those
rallies where people stood in line for
hours and the cold and he has to be
willing to walk away
yes walk away from a bad deal just the
way Reagan walked away from a bad deal
with the Soviets at Reykjavik look we
all understand that governance is
difficult and sometimes you have to get
the best deal you can with the votes
you're given but I think Kevin McCarthy
who's not exactly an immigration
hardliner had it right when he cautioned
the president yesterday during that
meeting
he said look you can't agree to a deal
that compounds the problem a deal that
ends up only attracting more illegals
down the road right now we have another
surge happening at the border and one
that fails to fortify the border really
fortify it now there's a possibility
that President Trump is doing something
else and I'm gonna leave this
possibility open that he's playing a
really smooth game with Republicans and
Democrats and the media so while he
conveys an openness to negotiating your
great Dianne no your great dick I love
you guys
well he's forcefully staking out his
ground and managing to bring all parties
to the table and it's not just that just
this week there are really encouraging
signs the president is actually doing
the hard work of enforcement he just
announced that 200,000 Salvadorans who
were supposed to be here temporarily
been here for about 25 years are going
to finally have to go home because guess
what the Hurricanes over and today the
administration raided about a hundred
seven 11's hunting for legal employee
and going after the employers who are
abusing them and abusing the system this
is the kind of robust proactive
enforcement that Americans expect and
his supporters demanded but when it
comes to any daca deal the president has
got to realize there are just two things
that matter above all else
number one doc is the only leverage the
president has to implement his entire
immigration agenda and number two
Democrats favor granting citizenship to
these illegal aliens because they
believe it is the absolute key to
achieving a supermajority just like the
one they currently have in California
they want that in every key battleground
state so there's so much more at stake
than just the future of the dreamers
this deal could decide the fate of the
country I'm gonna wait to see what the
final doctor proposal looks like but if
it does not include a wall a real wall
not a see-through wall expect a
political revolt from the base which
means losing the house and maybe even
losing the Senate and by the way chain
migration absolutely necessary so if he
doesn't if those things aren't in the
deal or the water down so badly they
don't really exist at all we end up
losing the house the Senate who's gonna
be left to defend the president dick
Durbin
Lindsey Graham are all those hard right
people who host radio shows are on Fox
News the president did not promise his
supporters an opaque electronic fence
that only covers a third of the border
he promised them a wall a big beautiful
wall and unless it's built less chain
migration has ended I fear mr. president
your most ardent supporters will write
you off as just another politician who
said something he didn't really mean and
that would be heartbreaking and that's
the angle